Speaker 1: Here's a voicemail at two one nine
two.
David, P..
There really doesn't make a lot of sense to
me.
It's one of these where someone is projecting
onto me something, I guess from somewhere
else, this time about Dr. Fauci.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: David, I'm not really sure why
you're still cheerleading Anthony Fauci at
this point.
It's pretty clear from all the news coming
out recently that the man is a liar and a
proven liar.
He clearly knew that this virus came from
more than just a natural mean look.
And so the emails released, they're real.
I think he should be fired and he should be
ashamed of himself.
He was never a very good person at his position
dealing with epidemics or pandemics.
Listen, listen.
Speaker 1: First of all, nothing has been
proven about the origins of the virus other
than what we currently know, which is it seems
to have come from animals and jumped to humans
once.
If and when we have proof of something other
than that, I will talk about it in terms of
cheerleading Anthony Fauci.
I don't know that you really seen my show.
I don't really care about Dr. Fauci as an
individual.
What I do know is that the smear campaigns
against him and his motives are not based
in evidence or facts.
And I am a cheerleader for the best empirical
knowledge that we have at the time.
That's what you can always count on on this
program.
What do we know based on actual studies right
now?
That's what you are going to get from me.
Not cheerleading of individuals or anything
like it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the Joe Rogan response
to the Spotify dust-up.
We're going to talk about the California Universal
Health Care Bill.
It's dead without even a vote, how we'll talk
about it.
And we will also talk about the fifth New
York prosecutor, who has now declined to file
sexual harassment charges against the former
governor, Andrew Cuomo.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.
Get instant access
Unidentified: and I will see you that.